the witcher's beautiful cinematography
and heart-pounding strigas shaking
coin-tossing action makes every frame
worth poring over in examining but some
moments in particular stand out for
being scrutinized by fans time and time
again in the fantastic and fast-paced
series premiere of The Witcher there
were a lot of moments that had people
pausing to get a better look at the
details there were also a few that were
paused so viewers could figure out just
what the heck was going on we're
introduced to her title character Henry
Cavill is Geralt of Rivia also known as
the white wolf and the butcher of
lovicott we're told of his witcher in
ways to zooming across time and space
for flashbacks and exposition told that
a chronological order and given plenty
of information about how this strange
magical world works 60 women wearing go
groans who to fill the room Oh Betty's
with bullet doesn't rhyme
oh good predictions rhyme in addition to
letting us know why there are so many
monsters hanging around in dire need of
witchery that first episode builds
tension slowly we along with Gerald come
to realize that the problems he faces
aren't going to be as simple as finding
a monster and stabbing it a bunch
finally we get the climax and a
jaw-dropping fight scene crammed with an
explosive series of whiplash inducing
action moves
Gerald's swordplay and the fantastic
fight choreography are the real heroes
on display people kept pausing to take
in the incredible battle that earns The
Witcher the grisly nickname that will
follow him for the rest of his life
the butcher of lovicott this action
sequence turned heads and occasionally
severed them with its lightning fast
moves amazing editing and technical
perfection that left audiences going
through every single moment of the scene
asking how they do that episode to
continue serving up more stellar scenes
as the story begins to expand beyond our
hero the narrative splits as it weaves
more important characters into its
complex time-bending story and every one
of them has a hand in a greater destiny
of the witcher's world Geralt meets his
bestie bard gasps gear in this episode
and regardless of how curmudgeonly
Jerrold acts toward the sweet voiced
song Smith they kick off the high
fantasy equivalent of a buddy cop comedy
dynamic right away the butcher of
Babacan
come here yeah some local town spoke
have claimed to see a devil nearby that
sends hacking up devils and demons are
the bread and butter of The Witcher in
job Geralt signs up to hunt it down
yes gear comes with him annoying Geralt
with his attempts to make him the star
of a loop-based rock opera when they
track down what folks thought was a
devil they actually find a magical
humanoid known as a Sylvan the
Otherworld the appearance of this
creature gives Geralt and audiences
pause the flawless effects make this
monster seem like it's jumping off the
screen and people stopped the show to
scrutinize the sylvans goat-like eyes
expressive face and very cool looking
horns
despite its shocking appearance and the
fact that they get into a massive
fistfight at first the witcher learns
that the sylvan is actually aiding
elvish refugees Geraldton yeah skier
leaved the sylvan and the elves and
peace and go on their merry way a solid
story but to be honest that's not the
most memorable thing about this episode
this was after all the story that
inspired gasps gears meme worthy number
one Bop toss a coin to your witcher
which we haven't been able to get out of
her head since episode 2 also introduces
another key character to The Witcher
Sokka yennefer of vengerberg who brings
another moment that made fans gasp and
scrambled to pause the show it happens
in what is basically an extremely
abusive Hogwarts for women that serves
as a training ground for a cult of
sorcery since we first meet yennefer is
a young girl and fans of the beautiful
spellcaster from the best-selling video
game witcher 3 or promo photos of
stunning actress anya chill l'autre
might not recognize their heroine she's
badly abused and ostracized by her
family and community luckily to the
audience her physical deformities and
initially timid nature puts us all
solidly on Team yin when she's plucked
from her terrible childhood by a less
than kindly mentor after exhibiting
magical powers while her fortunes are
changing it's definitely not an easy
road for the young witch in training
near the episodes end the scene when she
takes a stance and crosses the threshold
from down trodden victim to power-hungry
maven leaves fans hitting pause and
wondering just how far yen will go to
achieve ER ends clapping these eel slash
classmates into the murky pool
surrounding the testing ground shows us
yen's very deep dark side and
illustrates beautifully just how far
she'll go to take back the power that
the world is denied her for all these
years the third episode of The Witcher
pushes deeper into yen's origin story
and her psyche as we can
to some new territory in her past at
first sorceress training is going great
yen's excelling and her mentor to saya
is guiding her and trying to instill
some confidence in the young winch
heartbreakingly yen is still unsatisfied
with the appearance which caused her so
much pain as a child now that she's a
mighty magic wielders she's got options
Yetta likes to have a little magical
cosmetic surgery and decides that she's
in too much of a hurry to bother with
anesthesia still she's got an extremely
experienced wizard surgeon and yet is
prepared to go to any lengths to become
who she wants to be with everyone
watching
this scene is brutal and spares no
detail of yen's body being physically
reshaped leaving some folks pausing just
to catch their breath and get a moment's
respite from the screams that's all
intentional though the stellar lighting
and cinematography and are cut with
Gerald's deadly battle with the
monstrous Strega create a hellish
atmosphere which pull the audience along
during yen's pain the end result is the
conventionally beautiful witch that we
saw in the game but now we know exactly
what the cost of those good looks is
speaking of the stree go episode 3 also
brings us back to Geralt as he witchers
his way towards a destiny which will
shake the entire world while univers
harrowing story is playing out we also
see Geralt hunt for this miss shape and
monster and the story leading up to the
battle is a twisted tale of tragedy
that's every bit as sorrowful as Yin's
Geralt is called in by tris miracle to
help apprehend the horrifying creature
that's been terrorizing a village for
years and get to the bottom of the curse
that brought it on in the first place
The Witcher finds that the streak ax is
actually a product of some let's just
call it a lannister style relationship
between the king and his sister a
jealous adviser in love with the King's
sister attempted to curse the king but
the spell went awry it wound up cursing
and killing the mother instead causing
her baby to become a monstrous
bloodthirsty streak ax while the story
is as gruesome as it gets it does give
us this amazing monster battle scene
that uses movie magic to full affect the
shadowy lighting and quick cuts
interspersed with slow tense waiting
make this fight scene one of the
highlights of the whole first season
after all the scariest monsters are
always the ones you can never quite see
leading plenty of viewers to make
ourselves a little less frightened by
pausing the action to try to get a good
look trust us even seeing this nightmare
in crystal-clear HD wouldn't make it any
sprite me it's not all violence and
horror when it comes to the witcher's
most plausible moments some of them are
downright Pleasant Geralt of Rivia is
one dirty boy especially after being
swallowed by a monster living in an icy
lake and then fighting his way out from
the inside at first he seems okay with
his coating of monster guts despite the
smell but that wily Bard yeah skier
insists that Geralt act as his bodyguard
at a fancy ball so he's got to clean up
his act fans of gerelds video game
counterparts in the witcher 3 the Wild
Hunt will instantly recognize this
iconic scene of our favorite Witcher in
the bathtub
the production team behind the Netflix
show absolutely nailed the lighting and
look of their live action version of the
scene plus it gives us some great banter
between ya skier and is progres G muse
Geralt the witty back and forth and the
fascinating magic that is cavils Wiig
means fans can't take their eyes off the
scene well let's be real we all know the
true star of the scene is gerelds bear
brawny chest all that monster hunting is
paying off because the guy is cut
episode 5 takes Geralt in his fans on a
very wild very sexy ride that peeked
plenty of interest in viewers and sent
at least a few of them in search of a
freeze-frame to take it all in that wily
bar yeah skiers landed Geralt in hot
water once again except this time it's
not the nice relaxing bath that we might
have hoped for that happens later the
two monster hunting pros have literally
fished up a magical wish-granting gin
which is an extremely powerful magical
beam they've got three wishes and the
first ones are not used very wisely
Geralt wishes you a skier would shut up
for once and winds up getting exactly
what he wants there are only
ishes oh come on you always say you want
nothing from life so how was I supposed
to know you buddy three wishes old Terry
gasps Kyra's on the verge of death from
a wish gone wrong but there's a powerful
sorceress nearby who might be able to
help and her name just happens to be
yennefer of vengerberg Geralt drags his
Bartok buddy down the road in search of
some healing magic it's a race against
time as a skiers throat closes up
threatening to cut off his breath
permanently and give Geralt as much
desired peace
fortunately they find Yin posted up in a
little town where she is while making
the most of her circumstances the
beautiful enchantress has through
magical means coerced the whole once
puritanical town into a massive party
that's gone way past pg-13 mind
controlling the whole town into some
late-night cinematic style entertainment
because she's bored definitely isn't the
coolest thing yet has ever done
still the details in costuming or lack
of costuming of the Eyes Wide Shut style
festivities is impressive gerelds
deadpan grumpiness in the face of this
thirst trap makes us pause for sure
probably with the same low-key a skier
hat on our faces the final episode of
the witcher's first season takes magical
warfare to some incredible new heights
after building up the threat all season
the forces of nilfgaard which have an
intense hatred for magical beings like
the elves finally make their move
against our heroes in the north
yennefer and her allies have chosen to
make a last stand with the north in the
face of what seems like insurmountable
odds
nope Gard is incredibly strong and
willing to use any means necessary to
defeat their enemies up to and including
sacrificing their own magic users
training them up their power and life in
order to cast devastating spells against
the enemy forces bad news for those
witcher's and service denote Gard good
news for fans who want to see some
awesome and imaginative battle scenes
episode 7 is full of cool magical
moments a living wall of thorny vines
blocking troops from breaching enemy
lines
a guy with a seemingly endless supply of
deadly blades an enchanted box of creepy
metal worms that blow like mercury and
tons of flames scorching the earth with
magic artillery that vaporizes enemy
soldiers there are lots of memorable
moments at Vans paused and lingered over
in this episode they're only made more
impressive by the fact that Geralt
himself isn't involved in the fight
leaving the supporting cast to carry the
season finales climactic battle without
the main character with the epic
storytelling and a thrilling way the
tide of the battle goes back in
up until the very last minute Witcher
fans will be going back to this episode
again and again check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]